60s and as many books on economics he's
interviewed by his biographer Richard
Parker at Harvard University this is
just over an hour tonight it is my very
high privilege and very distinct honor
to introduce Trulia forum for the ages a
forum event with an American legend a
forum event with a true American icon
born in neighboring Canada in nineteen
eight and because he was born in Canada
that's the reason we probably never ran
him for president yes someone by the
name of John Kenneth Galbraith who
hasn't walked with kings and queens he
has become one of the most influential
economists of the twentieth century is
authored over 41 books he has served as
a close advisor to President Roosevelt
Truman Kennedy Johnson Carter and
Clinton and he will be talking about
some of these individuals during the
course of this conversation with you
this afternoon but perhaps his greatest
accomplishment has been his marriage
to Kitty and Kitty we thank you for
sharing once again professor
Thank You Katie
thank you
to interview our special guest this
afternoon is our friend and my neighbor
at Quincy house Professor Richard Parker
Richard is the author of the forthcoming
book John Kenneth Galbraith the maker of
American economics professor Galbraith
we want to thank you we want to thank
professor Parker both of you for being
here this afternoon and especially
Richard for all of the work and all of
the help that you have been in helping
to arrange for our very distinguished
visitor to come to the Kennedy School of
Government forum this afternoon
professor Richard Parker thank you
Thank You senator Pryor for that very
kind introduction well here at Harvard
and especially here at the forum I think
it's safe to say that we're quite
familiar with celebrity where I'm
sitting here tonight have stood
presidents and Kings movie stars and
Nobel laureates four-star generals and
finance ministers but with due respect
to them all let me say that we here are
less familiar with Fame celebrity in
this age of infotainment and television
touches many but is so often a passing
thing Fame however touches a few and
unlike celebrity indoors with me tonight
is one of the nation's if not the
world's most famous man John Kenneth
Galbraith his fame fortunately makes my
task easier for it allows me to be brief
more than once professor Galbraith has
said that for a competent Harvard
professor there should be no subject
however large but it cannot be
adequately presented in 50 minutes the
standard length of a Harvard classroom
lecture but professor Galbraith himself
is the living exception to that rule
because in 50 minutes I could barely
begin to list his accomplishments the
senator pryor is noted he's the author
of nearly four dozen books to which I
might add four dozen books which have
sold more than 10 million copies and
three dozen languages in more than 60
countries around the world he has been
not only the president of the American
economics Association but also of the
American Academy of Arts and Letters a
testimony to his range he holds honorary
degrees from more than 50 universities
including Harvard and Oxford curiously
enough not Yale but we will not speak of
that other place this evening China of
Kennedy won a mint mention Moscow and
Moscow and Moscow State University i
will also add in lieu of yale moreover
he's been honored by france with the
Legion of Honor by Canada with his
highest civilian award the Order of
Canada and by India with its highest
award and I might mention here in the
United States he has been given the
nation's highest civilian award the
order of freedom not once but twice the
only American ever to be so honored
during the Second World War at the age
of just 32 he became the nation's prices
are in charge of all civilian prices and
thereby the chief manager of America's
wartime economy at war's end he became
director of the Air Force's strategic
bombing survey that's still the most
powerful examination the strategic air
power the country has ever produced
after the war the State Department then
put him in charge of planning the
economic reconstruction of both Germany
and Japan
still in his 30s he even found time to
become for several years the senior
editor of Fortune magazine where he
introduced America's most powerful
business executives to the ideas of John
Maynard Keynes
as well as his own he was for Adlai
Stevenson in 1952 and 1956 a principal
speechwriter and advisor for President
Kennedy of course he was ambassador to
India and much more personal confidant
Sage adviser the first among Kennedy's
inner circle to see and warn against the
folly that became Vietnam not in 1963
not in 1962 but in 1961 three months
after President Kennedy took office four
time he also served Lyndon Johnson
especially in the early days of planning
the war on poverty but as the war in
Southeast Asia grew Ken Galvez took up
the role of critic into center lending
his voice to the campaigns to end the
war and transform the Democratic Party
as well as the country he recruited
Eugene McCarthy to run for president in
1968 and it was at the center of the
George McGovern campaign in 1972 but
beginning in the 1970s men like him
found themselves increasingly isolated
in some cases rebuked
richard nixon and later Ronald Reagan
and George Bush claimed that America was
a conservative country one moreover for
the markets and private wealth had been
unfairly fettered in their natural and
rightful power and rank many fell in
line with this new wisdom but Ken
Galbraith was not among them throughout
the 1970s and 80s and 90s as in the
years before then he continued to speak
and write on behalf of a richer
understanding of America and its place
in the world of our obligations to the
poor and of the necessity that
democracies oppose entrenched privilege
and power wherever they arose in book
after book article after article speech
after speech he argued not only for the
widest and most generous understanding
of democracy as inclusive and
egalitarian but the right and
responsibility of democratic citizens to
direct the economy for public ends
moreover he also did it always with the
trademark Galbraith Ian Whip Thomas
Carlyle who once pronounced economics
the dismal science clearly never knew
ken Galbraith free Galbraith the
challenge we as Americans still face is
to rise farther than we have come today
to be more than a nation of as he once
put it the bland leading the bland in
this economists need to point to more
than optimal the prices for things that
help men and women see beyond the making
and getting of everyday life or in his
words a man who reads Business Week is
lost to fame one who reads Proust is
marked for greatness this evening with
professor Galbraith were going to
remember a few things from the past but
also talk as some things of the present
and of the future I have no doubt you
were going to enjoy it professor
Galbraith and would start by asking you
to talk about three American presidents
and their wives men and women you've
known personally Franklin and Eleanor
Roosevelt John and Jacqueline Kennedy
and Lyndon and Lady Bird Johnson and
what they symbolized for you well
I have to recover from my deep delight
in that account of my history and tell
you how much I enjoy being here how much
I appreciate the comments of the senator
from Arkansas which causes me to mention
one of the great mysteries of American
political life which is why do all are
really good politicians come from either
Massachusetts or Arkansas other night as
some of you will remember my mind went
back to a hearing some time and then
1940s or 1950s on the stock market and
senator I got the story wrong that night
while I was testifying the stock market
took a massive slow and I didn't know it
but everybody else did and Senator
Fulbright when it came time for
questions said professor I must say I
was devoted to Fulbright he was one of
my closest friends
he said professor if the stock market
Falls out of beds one today will be
blamed for it one week and I didn't know
what was happening and I said it's a
wall of insured senator that would be a
short-run comment but the history
historians
we'll forgive you and us and he said
could I remind you professor that I am
up for election this are the manat those
historians they buy pleasure in the
evening is modified of course by the
extent that you will have to suffer
because make all people given to
personal history I enjoy hearing of my
own from myself
Franklin D Roosevelt and Eleanor
Roosevelt have always had been the
largest figures the largest political
figures in my life and the life of my
generation I had two extended encounters
with FDR one just before World War two
when I was brought to the White House
for a study of the relief programs which
I conducted for a couple of years a leap
I was on leave partly from Harvard and
later from Princeton and it was a lovely
experience but I saw very little of FDR
mostly I got encouragement and one of
the great moments of that time was
something that brought a shrewd like
an FDR it was down at Warm Springs he
was downstairs there Kenny and I have
visited it since and the question came
out about the great relief programs many
of which most of which involves some
building and certainly emphases be as
Harry Hopkins wanted on the work that
was provided the people that needed
those jobs should that be the basis of
decision or should as Harold Ickes
wanted and he had charge of the building
that resulted the Triborough bridge or
whatever it was that that was what
historians would celebrate people would
celebrate and that should be the tale
when Harry Hopkins had finished FDR said
Harry you're perfectly right and then
the afternoon one ickiest came in and
made his speech FDR said Harold you're
perfectly right
and Eleanor who had been listening to
these hearings and saying it all in when
they had both gone said Franklin I just
don't understand you
Harold comes in here you tell him he's
perfectly right Harry comes in here and
you tell says something totally
different and you tell him he's
perfectly right I just don't understand
you
Roosevelt thought that over carefully
and said Eleanor you're perfectly right
the principle relationship I had with
FDR was during the war years when they
took prematurity early age I was put in
charge of price control and put in
charge of what was my own initiative the
general maximum price regulation which
provided that you could lower a price
but not increase it without government
permission and that lasted through the
war it worked we have in World War two
no memory of inflation where in World
War one prices doubled in the course of
two years and it gave me a very shrewd
view I thought at the time of both the
process of public administration and
the people who are running the economy I
have to tell you a story about that and
then I will get back to Roosevelt every
afternoon we had to hear in my rooms at
the offices when somebody came in to get
a higher price was suffering they were
business executives they were nice bro
quotes and collars nice blue coats and
white collars sanded a long table with
my staff and I would look down the table
as they made their case who was
full-employment good struttin strong
floors of orders the best profits since
before the Great Depression and my staff
would have their hands going like this
on the table and from now on it is
something you should remember and you
may on occasion have a lecture at
Harvard where you will need it that
refers to the great period when there
was a terrible shortage of food a
terrible drought in hay and country
affecting an anthill
on the side of a great hill and the
queen ant mobilized the troops to go and
look for food and presently one day a
group of ants that she'd sent out a
detachment came galloping back down the
hill to where this ant colony was
situated halfway down
to say that a fine piece of food horse
manure had just been discovered at the
top of the hill and she immobilized a
forceout to bring it back and it was
necessary to hold against it because the
hill was steep and there was danger that
it would write down and be lost since
she got more and more of her troops to
hold against it and she went up and down
with her aunt and I going like this
which in ant language means stop that
horse [ __ ] I would look down my table
and my very reputable staff would be
going like this and as I say that is
something which I give to you now for
all future use maybe even tonight what
question was I supposed to end
I think I know you well enough that a
question to the you is simply pointed in
your direction that you will that take
it where it will lead Franklin and
Eleanor Roosevelt John and Jacqueline
Kennedy Lyndon and lady Burgess oh they
they're both Franklin Roosevelt and in
some one lesser measure Elinor looked at
the United States looked at all the
states as an extension of Hyde Park for
which they had the responsibilities of
the couple the family in charge not as
landlords but the responsibility for
everything on the estate and he did this
in the case of FDR was a human concern
how these people were surviving and
suffering and what could be done
it wasn't an ideological reaction
eleanor was more of a liberal and this
carried her into matters including race
relations voting power and relief into a
deeper commitment than FDR one
consequence of which was that then and
again in the war years when we had
something about which we felt very high
a very high level of urgency we went to
Eleanor rather than the FDR for two
reasons first we had a more sympathetic
audience and second we could get an
appointment and
over her lifetime she was my one of my
best loves friends and there should be
no doubt that in their humane commitment
at home and abroad that the position of
FDR was enormous he strengthened by the
association he had with Ellen who else
still have to talk with the Kennedys
well this was a for me a very different
situation I lived when I first came to
Harvard 1934 believe it or not in winter
house and I are two of our most
distinguished presidents were the two
Kennedy brothers Joe and the president
the president to be and through them and
through a long association I'd had with
their father not a long association but
a close one I came to know them very
well and I came particularly to admire
Joe Kennedy one of the tragedies of
American life was that one of the ablest
undergraduates Harvard ever had was lost
during World War two Thea and it was
from that background that life began
with John F Kennedy who was intelligent
attractive and not given to an excessive
amount of work yeah he had that highly
cultivated detachment from labour marks
still to this day a certain part of the
undergraduate body and from that came
politics from that came support and I
was identified to some extent with his
campaigns for Congress and very much
with the presidential campaign very much
if there was a part of the country where
there was no hope or not much hope of
election but where they had as somebody
who was held to be close to Kennedy
I was sent and I became in that campaign
a real expert on the democratically
hopeless parts the country but there was
there was more because of Kennedy's
father
there was a strong rift between the
Roosevelts and the Kennedys and mrs.
Roosevelt did not come out for Kennedy
when he announced that he was coming
running for president she was totally
detached and even opposed
but she was at that time giving some
lectures television lectures at Brandeis
and I had took on the job of persuading
her that Kennedy was not Jo and that he
was someone she should support and she
finally said this was the wonderful
thing that she would judge she would
make the decision but she would like
first to ever have him come on their
television program wonderful I gotten
sense with him he came up was New Year's
Day he went on the program and it went
beautifully and there was a huge press
conference afterward and inevitably the
first question was mrs. Roosevelt does
senator Kennedy appearing here mean that
you will be supporting him for the
nomination
she said it certainly does not and that
left the whole program behind or was the
dominant news the next day and that
night
Kitty and I went over as we often did on
a Saturday night to look over some
famous restaurant in those days for
dinner was one or two others including
professor Slater and the first as we sat
down Kennedy said you know something I
always saw that it might happen that
there would be somebody who's the
college professor who would have some
grace and ability on political matters
but can you prove it will never happen
they who else the Texan LBJ he was in
some ways the most misunderstood man we
ever had in the White House I had known
him from his days in Congress and had
been a consistent admirer and subject of
amusement he was a wonderful companion
and this was helped by the fact that we
were exactly the same age three months
of flower and were naturally in
Washington thrown together in the same
age group and became close friends and
with the passage of time I visited him
down Texas went bird hunting with him
one day I didn't want to admit to him as
a Texas sports one that I had never shot
a gun so I went into my Jeep and he took
his Jeep and I pointed the gun up close
my eyes and fired it the doves in Texas
have never been so safe and then came
Vietnam and this was something that
turned out one of the ablest political
leaders in our history particularly in
his relations with the Congress at
parrot his enormous commitment to the
poor and the working community from
which he himself had in some measure
graduated and most important of all was
Lyndon Johnson's commitment to civil
equality and race route and race
relations we have already to this day
forgotten we have to this day for God
that were after Lyndon Johnson one can
go to the South without knowing that
they were without expecting some sort of
upset in a restaurant or in the back of
the bus
this was his not this was his
contribution so far as anybody in
politics could make a contribution and
as I say that was plastered over by the
Vietnam War I have two recollections of
that one is the great riot at Chicago
for gene McCarthy a riotous evening in
the parks and a riotous evening in the
convention
I was jeans floor manager and I have to
tell you that that was an experience
which I wouldn't recommend to anybody to
be a manager with
one taking her management is well I know
as I say I don't wish anybody would have
the experience but that was the night I
must say if a personal role that I knew
the Vietnam War was coming to an end
because we took turns going across
Michigan Avenue from the hotel to a mass
of people in the park who were
demonstrating against the war and the
great riots and protecting the hotel
which was the headquarters of both of
the of all the candidates of both
candidates was a line of National
Guardsmen and standing
shoulder-to-shoulder along the front and
I went through them my night got up in
the platform that had been rigged up and
made a report on what we were doing in
organizing against the war and also my
plea that they stay away from violent
action Mayor Daley's police are always
going to be better at that than you are
and it's just a matter of common sense
to take a peaceful position and then
immediately regretting I had said it I
said I said I don't want you trying do
Cluj ins with these national guardsmen
we're standing here behind me and then
immediately I said just keep in mind
their draft dodger system
say masseur and immediately knew that I
had said the wrong thing and that was
when I knew the war was coming to an end
that was my closing lines and they as I
finished the sergeant who was in charge
came up on the platform and said sir
could I have a word with you and I knew
that I was going to get it he said I
just want to shake your hand and that's
the best thing that's been said about us
all day and that was my knowledge that
the war was over sorry
no not at all your uh your government
service has always been in support of
Democratic presidents but you've also
known some Republicans as well - Richard
Nixon and Ronald Reagan in particular
would you mind giving us a few words on
that well I didn't know Nixon personally
and a few years ago I went down to give
a lecture to the staff of the National
Archives and they dug up all the adverse
papers that they could find on me which
is what they do for any speaker and made
the discovery or that I had not known
that Richard Nixon was on my staff at
the office of Price Administration and
had written my letters and he was on the
the paper facsimile papers that they
gave me I am an anything must add on
Richard Nixon
because comes me the worst weekend I
ever had on a Saturday we were up in
Vermont he published there was published
the enemies list and I was on it with
two check marks and everybody I knew
called up and said how the hell did you
get on that list and I didn't there was
a mass of jealousy well that's my view
of Richard named Raymond I never met it
Ronald Reagan and I did know each other
we were both founders of Americans for
democratic action Ad Age a dominant
liberal group of that time and I knew
him partly because he was one of the
avenues of money that came to a DA from
Hollywood which we very much appreciated
it
nothing smoothes the relationships so
much as a chair and then he went out on
a lecture tour for General Electric for
several months and began reading the
material was suggested to him by for the
audiences and came to believe it
unfortunately but
it has to be said for Ronald Reagan as
it had to be said for his wife they had
one great virtue they both enjoyed the
job much more than they concern
themselves with the policy and that was
good
and
and now in this day and age I could be
one of the very few people in the very
few people with some Democratic Party
tradition who yearns for Ronald Reagan
instead of our present situation you for
many years have been among the most
distinguished students of the British
economist John Maynard Keynes and yet in
your works developed your own
distinctive brand of thought that some
have come to call the Galbraith Ian
system would you care to describe for
the audience what you think the elements
the most important elements of the
Galbraith Ian system and economics are
well I I was greatly taken as all my
generation in the 30s in the late
thirties by John Maynard Keynes and went
to Cambridge England for a year to study
under him that was the year he had his
first heart attack and I never and he
never came to the University there is no
doubt about the importance of the vision
he gave as to public policy
macroeconomic policy in those days here
at Harvard we had two classes of
economists those who were still in the
19th century and very keen to get back
to the 18th
and those who were marked more martyred
and had the established marsh alien view
of the economy with great emphasis on
the role of Monopoly corporate price
fixing in Chamberlain's monopolistic
competition which captured the largest
part of the of the teaching and student
position and then there was a small
minority who had gone on to a solid left
position that was that and and they held
those of us who were more responsible
and more cautious with a certain
discomfort and even this day this was
the mood of Harvard prior to Kings with
as I say the greatest emphasis on
impairment of the wage price and the
price demand structure the first book I
ever wrote was on that boasts one of the
most disastrous experiences of my life
it was called modern competition and
business policy and related the
depression to the fact that there were
dominant influences holding up prices
and limiting production in contrast with
agriculture where they where the
production is not controlled where where
there's full employment and much lower
prices
and in the spring of 1937 just as that
book went to press
I read canes and changed my mind but the
book was and gone to press and it got
very good reviews from all of the
economists with whom I disagree the
contribution of cases went far beyond
economics incidentally but it was the
first record of overview of
macroeconomic policy imposed on the
government on the state that you
provided that by the state through
employment or through state-sponsored
investment the employment the income the
purchasing power that did not come from
the private sector and that that was a
sweeping view partly because of his
extreme plausibility and those of you
who were here at Harvard should not be
in any doubt it was at Harvard that
those ideas to Harvard that those ideas
came to the United States it was
impossible after 1937 to avoid an
evening seminar on k's and they went
through most of the daytime and if there
was nothing else that you could do you
could go to a meeting with xu vader to
hear him denounce kids
which he did in a very eloquent way and
this was one of those rare times when
every week somebody some group came up
from Washington from the civil service
to discuss these matters they came to
Alan Hansen seminar so that this was in
economics a break point for a whole
generation of which to which I belong
belong moving from old-fashioned
economics including market structures
monopolies and competition to the notion
of a public responsibility for
maintaining the purchasing power they
would keep people keep businesses going
keep people over to work it was a very
interesting time you've uh had a few
critics within the economics profession
you have had one or two critics within
the economics profession certainly at
the University of Chicago the home of
your good friend Milton Friedman but
there was also another University of
Chicago economist George Stigler
who as I recall on reviewing a book of
yours remarked that too many people were
reading professor Galbraith and not
enough were reading Adam Smith do you
happen to recall your reply to Professor
Stigler I I said I I thought the point
was well-taken but incomplete that they
his great tragedy his great sense was
how few people are reading stigma at all
but I I have a good relationship always
an inner relationship with Milton
Friedman because he made me president of
the American economic system he was on
the board when my name came up and I I
had a majority and he raised or was near
a majority and Milton raised them his
objection that Galbraith was not the
type of economist that should be hint of
a professional academic scientific group
and developed that point and his closing
comment was that is keep in mind that
source Stein babblin was never head of
this organization and that was so
damaging so much cause so much sense of
guilt that I went through the next five
minutes professor Galbraith in economics
as well as in politics you've long been
associated with what some today refer to
only as the l word or when they refer to
it at all talk of it as a thing of the
past
what is liberalism mean to you and how
relevant is it - it's all I don't
believe in categories there's there's
some matters where you want many matters
where you want to exempt yourself from
doctrine and apply your view in the
particular case most of the of the are
the results of what of that
I suppose caused me to be called the
liberal but it is practical or once one
senses to be the practicable judgment
for the well-being of people it should
be the controlling doctrine and that's
what I try to have so if somebody wants
to call me liberal I'm prepared to
accept it like it and ignore it you've
been thinking quite a bit from our
conversations earlier about Enron these
days would you care to share your
thoughts with us what the question again
I didn't get it you and I have talked in
recent weeks about shirt interest in the
Enron matter would you care to share
some thoughts well this is something
that was in a sense predictable even
though it wasn't predicted in the
there's a tendency for the large
corporation which in most cases one
shouldn't doubt has in a very effective
management but there is a possibility of
a step into error there of which Enron
was the Magnificent example of a
situation in which the operation of the
controls within the corporation that are
required simply get misplaced and for
the most part they do but the average
they don't get misplaced for the most
part in the corporation is a effective
instrument for its own for first
purposes
that is why we no longer speak of
capitalism people who simply have money
do not have the capacity or intelligence
to run a modern corporation the
stockholders are paid a commonplace
amount and instructed to register their
position on matters which when they
register their position accept make a
proposal a uniformly ignored and but one
shouldn't doubt that the corporation as
we have it is something that works we
can worry about the extent to which it
intrudes on public policy we should all
worry about the way in which what is
still called the public sector has been
taken over in the military area the
power of the defense industries but it
works and what was your question but I
think I'd like to do is actually invite
some of our audience to join us for a
questions which you step forward to the
microphone we'll take just a few
questions here there's one over here and
I believe they're one and two up there
as well I'll have you repeat them I
shall do you want to pick up on
yes professor Galvez Manny's name is
nuit Erman from the K School of
Government please speak slowly though
you touched upon your relation to Milton
Friedman and Paul Samuelson once said
about Friedman that he has a lot of
gifts and talents he's blessed with but
not the gift of the maybe and I wanted
to ask you if you could elaborate on
your personal relationship and your view
of Friedman as an economist a little bit
more there near your views of Milton
Friedman as an economist well your your
views of Milton Friedman as an economist
my view of a very distinguished teacher
and the highest praise I can give it
he's civilized and comfortable and even
at times appealing I think that answers
my question big thank you up here we
have a question Simon political-economic
visiting there's one one thing I would
like to mention in 1997 I did predict
and wrong with debate in the debate with
Arthur Levitt and congressman Markey to
the tea market has audacity to use the
terminology that I use then but that's
not my question when I look at American
management at the executed pass of last
five years I am astonished by similarity
of character that reminds me Bolshevik
Roman clitoris 90% of American
executives think the same way elbows as
Bolsheviks how can we get out of it now
this is an interesting proposition for
someone with a graduate degree from
Moscow State University
your questioner says that in his
observation the managers of the great
American corporations think and behave
like Soviet Bolshevik bureaucrats which
you care to see whether there are
examples to be comparisons to be drawn
out there well I think they there's a
point there that if you're running a
large and complex organization no matter
where it is there will be certain
similarities but you shouldn't allow
ideology to intrude on that is one of
the facts of organization whether it's a
Washington bureaucracy a state
government or something in France or
Moscow so to draw conclusions from some
similarities between organizations is
something you should do but the key
similarity is that they are both trying
to steal as much as they can while it is
going on in a while they can thank you
very much yes I professor Galbraith
Ganesha German I'm a sophomore
undergraduate in the movie 13 days they
talk about how India and I think China
got into a conflict during the Cuban
Missile Crisis I was wondering if you
could comment on any role that you had
in you know alleviating that conflict or
conflicts in India in general when you
were ambassador what the student is
referring to just so the audience
understands is that in October 1962
during the Cuban Missile Crisis on
America and the Soviet Union almost
launched a nuclear war what happened was
that India and the Red China also went
to war
professor Galbraith was the United
States ambassador to India at the time
and was given almost carte blush by the
United States government to aid and
support the Indians in this matter I
think the student would like to have you
comment a little bit about this
experience this was a very intense time
and actually I had somewhat more
authority than I knew I had at the time
that film that has recently been
released has Kennedy to miss dismissing
the news of that war by saying all
Galvez is handling that
I so regarded myself I thought that I
was but didn't know that I had such
agreement in Washington the then
Secretary of State now Alaska Dean Ross
and I were not in the same wavelength
he was an old-fashioned cold warrior and
I was looking for a peaceful world and
we that brought us into a a difference
of view on quite a few important matters
but that was a minor episode which both
in China and in India got out of
proportion the excitement in India was
accessible and my depth of my concern
was accessible and the reality came one
morning about five o'clock in the
morning when news came that the Chinese
had offered a ceasefire and I got out of
bed got the car went and saw narrow to
urge him to accept it because in the
first place the conflict was over some
real estate
you could only hope would belong to
somebody else
and also if I may say so
Indian emotion was getting out of hand
and I have had many pleasant encounters
with Niro who was a really great figure
of the century but none that I
appreciated so much as that because I
was exactly the person he wanted to see
so then among other things he could
attribute the peace and the steps that
were needed to peace to the United
States he didn't but that was the
possibility while we're on the subject
of State the State Department you have
offered a famous analogy to the subject
of trying to communicate through the
State Department do you recall that it's
not the sort of thing that centers on at
a university but perhaps I could make
one exception during my time in India
and at other times I had a considerable
direct communication with Kennedy and
the White House and this was very
annoying to the State Department and
they sent a plea from mr. Roth to the
White House asking that I be instructed
to have all my communications come
through the State Department
and I said Kennedy who on the whole I
think likes my letters to my telegrams
he wasn't certainly put off by them
wired me sent a telegram asking what I
thought of it and I told Telegraph Bank
that I didn't like it that there was a
particular problem I put it in someone
more rough language communicating to the
State Department was like having sexual
intercourse through the blanket
certainly not a routine topic for the
university community one more question
one more question yes my name is Maria
Cristina College a doe I am a student
here an amazing fellow at the Kennedy
School I wonder how did you evaluate
their results of the u.s. drug policy at
the macroeconomic level and why would be
from your point of view the policy
options your let me be sure I understand
the question the question is professor
gallopers views about the u.s. drug
policy I think microeconomic level acro
economic level and whether he would
propose any alternatives
well Nicholas you're from Colombia of
course I am from Colombia no that's the
Colombia
well US drug policy I am I am NOT an
expert on such matters why should I have
they whipped up drugs roundest doubts
about the present drug policy and the
ocean that it can be controlled by legal
action the same problem that was faced
in my early youth with alcohol and that
we we better revert to education and
taxation
ladies and gentlemen as I promised when
we began this conversation we were going
to talk about some things past but also
some things of the present and of the
future I hope indeed that you have
enjoyed this conversation with professor
Galbraith tonight and I will repeat for
you once again his advice a man who
reads Business Week is lost to fame one
who roots Proust is marked for greatness
to the name Proust I would also add John
Kenneth Galbraith thank you
John Kenneth Galbraith is taught at
Harvard and Princeton University's been
the editor of Fortune magazine and
written many books on economics he was
interviewed by his biographer Richard
Parker whose book is John Kenneth
Galbraith the making of American
economics it's published by Ferrer
Straus and Giroux online at FS